[Music]
in hope for humanity news submitted by
Jacob from Seattle
what's up Jacob yeah a Kenyan science
teacher has won the title of best
teacher in the world Canyon Canyon there
was a war for the best teachers oh yeah
like everything has been coming out of
Kenya did you see that one are you dead
no what's a legit interview yeah this
guy who's like a television reporter was
she a lesbian or was she she I think
she's transgender because she claims to
be a man he was alone he says he's like
all seriousness suit Wow investigative
reporter you did Wow but this is a
genuine I am not gay I am a man so I am
straight that's the first question like
what yeah what did the rest of the
interviews online it was hilarity and in
a pastor came in and he was like pretty
much he had fruits and vegetables to
explain why straight sex is godly and
gay sex is ungodly this interview you
can't have another banana pudding to the
other banana we said some [ __ ] like that
every dad that's why awesome things are
coming out of Kenya and awesome well
this is pretty awesome you languages and
it's some good news people coming back
to life Peter cebiche I don't know if
I'm saying that right go through the
beat see a member of the Franciscan
religious order won the 2019 golden
teacher prize so brother pre Peter has
been praised for his achievements in is
really deprived school with crowded last
war brother Peter brother or brother
Peter that be back
disorders right now especially of the
Catholic one he gives away 80% of his
pay to to support his pupils because
it's just not enough money in their
school says whatever yeah he says there
is no teacher bad businessman but he won
an award and he got like millions of
dollars for it a million a million
dollars six year old teacher but I bet
you he's gonna spend those millions on
the kids privilege pending not frivolous
spending so right now they have teachers
there's like a lack of teachers in
classrooms for the amount of students
they have so there's teachers that are
supposed to be teaching 40 students
they're teaching
80 students at a time that's important
and he really just wants to spread
science and like make sure that females
are getting an education so a lot of in
there like area a lot of the families
don't send their girls to school because
they want their girls to get married and
start a family and all the stuff and
he's like no we need to keep our women
in schools and we need them to grow up
and like be educated and he wants to see
an Africa that's like like thriving and
active in art and the sciences and and
all of that stuff Oh beautiful he saw a
black panther one of the Conda forever
yeah he's like Conda can happen here
yeah he says because young people will
no longer be held back by low
expectations Africa will produce
scientists engineers entrepreneurs those
names will one day be famous in every
corner of the world and girls will be a
huge part of this story is that good
news makes me cry we were just talking
about this the other day a lot of people
don't know just because like my best
friend's he's he's uh he's Rwandan like
African culture is actually highly
similar Asian people like how they kind
of like carry their youth to go for a
lot of like highly professional job
medical medical specifically because it
has there's always an availability for
it like culturally speaking like how
they raise their kids it's very very
Asian like they beat the [ __ ] out of
their kids there is a reinforcement just
like Asian people this [ __ ] whatever
complim
I think they're the newest minority
group that are like hitting the Ivy
League's are like high-level colleges in
biggest numbers they're killing the game
man yeah so and in this area there's
like a lack of internet connection so he
has to go to a cyber cafe to download
resources so that he can teach the
science lessons
not unlike jk where you have to download
everything first because the Internet's
very slow here but many of the pupils
walk more than four miles on bad roads
to reach the school and so he just wants
to give them a chance to learn about
science and to raise their horizons like
make them believe in themselves and
stuff and she spends a lot of his own
money I was talking with friends one
time I was like how many good teachers
I want to public school a good public
school yeah yeah I'm like how me oh it's
a lot of different schools how many good
teachers out of all the teachers you had
were actually good teacher a good
teacher like not a lot some dumbass
came up with like you get one good one
you're hauling like 8th grade
there's a couple of good ones here in
there yeah both of them are just like
tolerating you but like one or two like
really like the impacted you yeah I miss
Senate miss senators they all impacted
me in a certain way because I had more
parent-teacher conferences than any
other student in every class so I knew
all of them on a personal level my mom
had every teachers telephone number
pretty so I could I have all my teachers
memorized and I could tell you like what
are you like you know what they ain't
they they taught me that the school
system is full of inefficiencies and
stupidity and the slowest way to teach
something yes super stupid
my math teacher straight up said go
ahead and try to fire me on tenure yeah
yeah yeah well guess what I had a math
teacher that was pregnant and one of the
students kicked her in the stomach in
Sacramento
raisi dude she is I don't give a [ __ ]
started getting in her face and
everybody wasn't kind of calm her down
and then she's like in this [ __ ]
teachers face and by the way she was the
sweetest lady [ __ ] the teacher was
yes and then she [ __ ] they had a
puller off and as we were pulling her
off she [ __ ] kicked her in the
stomach oh my god
what a [ __ ] was the baby okay baby was
okay but then I just remember like she
was like getting all loud and I'll -
that we all looked at her like I can't
be one that you [ __ ] kicked the
pregnant lady dude I would have spaded
that little girl got beat later and I'm
if I'm my other friend because she had a
big crush on her she would be feral type
dude she would be sterile did the
teacher get any Block in as it just went
straight was done I don't think anybody
would have thought anybody would
attacked her she's so [ __ ] sweet
and pregnant but she was nice to me and
other piece of [ __ ] was a pregnant lady
no pregnant woman in the stomach yeah
dude
she straight-up win it's hard to be
sweet when you're pregnant too yeah she
was like telling her to like she's gonna
beat her ass stuff we're like yo chill
and then when they kick in the stomach
cap and it got a little too real cuz
it's just words up into that she was two
words and then all sudden piece of [ __ ]
we need to throw that girl away yeah
cancel her I thought she's cute though
so yeah he did win a million dollar
prize that's cool yeah 1 million dollars
an American or king and I know an
American he's like a king there now
yeah well he's probably gonna put it all
back and so he is dude
85 person she doesn't ask for 85 percent
dude 10% 10%
tithing is 10% dude yeah he and his
Christian than he only a 5% Franciscan
friar a member of the Catholic religious
order the top of his head he works at a
restaurant - an air fryer
what are you doing no no like a fry like
a
like he has a ball cup but fire shut my
bad my bad if he's black it's not like
mr. burns it doesn't go down it just
poof's I like Krusty the Klown that
haircut like the bread ball hands you're
not supposed to get [ __ ] ever he
doesn't look like that though he looks
this is he I don't like [ __ ] picture
you better be in a burlap sack god damn
it not ruin my image of him oh my man's
can go to the youth alive know where
everybody's still where the Photoshop at
on grease and stuff they still with the
old school garments I thought he would
wear a burlap sack with the rope on his
waist no I mean Tabuchi yeah um to be
she says it's morning in Africa the
skies are clear the day is young and
there is a blank page waiting waiting to
be written it's this is Africa's time no
ma'am want this to do to be my dad right
now
[ __ ] reinforcing this [ __ ] that's the
kind of guy that should be in religion
oh yeah yeah huh that's the kind of guy
you want in religion right you know what
our future kids are so lucky because we
don't have stories that we could make
our kids feel bad about for like going
to school because did all your parents
tell you about how big school and other
they walked so dude we used to have our
trip to drive our own cars in traffic
you don't even know what toy maybe they
might have that [ __ ] huh yeah cuz my
parents always talking about [ __ ]
climbing up mountains having to go to
the temple to get water just for their
cup ramen is [ __ ] ours might even be one
to go to a building you couldn't you
couldn't just stay at home and no do
school in the bed you know we're on the
ground to be in school and computers
they just all sit there for like three
hours and like virtual classrooms we
need to teleport you would tell me that
you didn't want to send your kids at
school uh we kind of laughed about that
but I can't me I don't want to even know
cuz I just don't give it a
I become socially awkward yeah yeah
there's other things you can do to
instigate them so yeah you could get
them to there's there's extracurriculars
both right like when you're not acting
as a kid you had more like like
one-on-one I'd like well there's one
that you like better and how are they
different like regular school social too
much talk I needed to have a girl each
class that I wanted to go see what
they're wearing everyday like okay but
think about it think about it from a
parent's point of view right do you want
your kids to [ __ ] be infected by the
minds of dumbasses and be like them or
would you want them to try to challenge
themselves and elevate themselves in the
world and be around like smarter kids
and smarter people true but sooner or
later there's if their kids gonna be a
dumbass loser they're destined for it
that's true what if your kids know you
could do about it like your whatever
your cookie is the disease I'd rather it
be a disease in a full and a room full
of good news
all the smart people no smart people get
dumb you know I'm keeping them home to
protect [ __ ] raise your kid that's what
gets around people a super awkward
[ __ ] I already know your kids the
[ __ ] well I think that it's not like
they're gonna be home 24/7 it's it's
they're still gonna be educated but it's
effective education is what I believe
your kids gonna be the one standing on
top of the [ __ ] water fountain
[ __ ] splashing every give me a
brilliant just a brilliant person alone
I think your kid's gonna be the smart
kid but he's so [ __ ] future we can't
even wrap our head around that [ __ ] so
he seems dumb to us exactly he's a kid
that sees other people throw coins into
the wishing well he's like stupid and he
goes he takes all the money
is always sucking away free money
[ __ ] stupid yeah I don't know I don't
have a kill you get you guys are gonna
yes I mean no we don't have this figured
out yet so we don't know anything I just
I worry about just him being around like
other the other yeah I do
really yeah and you want to put him in
public school I do or all the morons are
here yeah the world is are morons you
know what sooner or later this is gonna
run into [ __ ] you should be able to
recognize it just a good public school
in a good area with good money yeah cuz
in Santa Barbara I went to another
different kind of public school you know
there are all Blue Ribbon Schools so
California like a science blue ribbons
to like schools that are public but
they're like legit good and that that
was those were the school set in Santa
Barbara so you could go to public
schools
[Music]
[Music]